the nation's richest landlords are
actually wealthier now than they were in
2022 there are 25 billionaires on the
2023 fors 4 100 list who primarily owe
their fortunes to real estate these
property tycoons are worth a collective
$1 139
billion about $5 billion more than the
24 in real estate were worth on the 2022
ranking here are the five richest real
estate billionaires on this year's forms
400 number five Jeff Green green made a
fortune buying credit default swaps on
subprime mortgage backed bonds during
the housing crisis in 2007 and 2008 he
then turned that profit into a portfolio
of Apartments condo buildings hotels and
office properties mostly in California
Florida and New York growth in those
assets helped add another estimated $300
million to Green's net worth over the
past year number four Igor alov alov
owns more than 8 million square ft of
office space and over 7 17,000
residential units in States including
Arizona California and Florida this year
he spent $165 million to buy two
apartment complexes in duth Georgia and
Raleigh North Carolina further expanding
his residential real estate holdings
number three Leonard
Stern Stern is best known as the
namesake of New York University's
business school thanks to $3 million
gift in 1988 but the prolific donor
draws his wealth from Harts Mountain a
firm that owns more than 260 properties
largely industrial plus offices hotels
and apartments strong demand for
industrial real estate and apartments
helped Stern grow his fortune by an
estimated $500 million over the past
year number two Steven Ross Ross's
related companies which he founded in
1972 is best known for the Hudson yards
development in New York it owns and
manages more than $60 billion in assets
stretching across the US Plus a joint
venture in London The Firm has also been
expanding into South Florida and is now
the largest owner of commercial real
estate in West Palm Beach Ross was also
the biggest real estate loser of the
past year his fortune shrunk by an
estimated $1.5
billion and at number one Donald Bren
through his Irvine Company Bren controls
a real estate Empire totaling more than
129 million square ft of Office
Buildings apartments and shopping malls
across California as well as a 97.5% s
stake in the medlife building in
Manhattan three office Towers in Chicago
and two golf
courses